SRINI DEVADAS: All right,
good morning, everyone.
Oh, do we have a
treat for you today.
I'm going to publicize, for
the first time, my hidden
talent of mind reading.
And since this is a
magic trick, you know,
every magician
needs an assistant.
And I want to introduce
Billy Moses to you.
Billy is a PhD student.
He already has three
degrees from MIT,
but he wants a fourth, I guess.
And so I'm going to turn
it over to Billy, here.
And Billy is going to
sort of set things up.
I'm just going to do my thing,
which is read your minds, OK?
So go ahead, Billy.
BILLY MOSES: So what's going
to happen is, I'm going to--
I have this card
deck right here,
normal card deck,
perfectly normal cards.
They're not in any weird order.
You can see them.
I'm going to give five people
the opportunity to pull a card
and then give it back to me.
They can look at the card.
Then what's going
to happen is, I'm
going to turn over four of these
cards, show you the final card.
And then Srini is trying-- going
to try to guess the fifth card.
SRINI DEVADAS: Well, but
what I need you to do
is, when I'm going to
guess, I need all of you
to really focus on that hidden
card, I mean, in your heads,
right?
So I can't do individual
mind reading, just
in case you guys were worried.
So if you think I'm wearing
a terrible-colored shirt,
I'm not going to know, OK?
But if you all think
of this hidden card,
I'm going to be
able to guess it.
But so I need some
help, all right?
BILLY MOSES: OK, anyone wants to
try pulling some of the cards?
OK.
SRINI DEVADAS: And I guess--
BILLY MOSES: Take
your favorite card.
SRINI DEVADAS:
--I can step out--
BILLY MOSES: --it
can be anywhere.
SRINI DEVADAS: --here, right?
BILLY MOSES: Yeah.
SRINI DEVADAS: All right.
BILLY MOSES: And look at it.
Give it back to me once you've--
cool.
Anyone else want to pick a card?
Want to pick a card?
Here you go.
You can look at the full deck,
look at whatever card you want,
pick it, cool.
SRINI DEVADAS: We're
doing a little trick.
BILLY MOSES: Anyone else
want to pick a card?
You want to pick a card?
OK, anyone else
want to pick a card?
Want to pick a card?
Cool, want to pick a card?
Cool, OK, I've got my
cards all nice together.
OK, so five cards, I'm
going to show you first.
And then we're going to present
them in a fun way for Srini
to see.
So the five cards
are as follows.
We have this wonderful
Seven of Clubs.
We have a Jack of Hearts.
We have Seven of Hearts.
We have Queen of Spades.
And we have Ten of Clubs.
Now, for the people
who pulled the card,
these are indeed the cards
that you gave me, right?
No one missed their
card in the deck?
OK, I'll go get Srini.
SRINI DEVADAS: All
right, ready for me?
BILLY MOSES: Yup.
OK, the first card is
the Seven of Clubs.
The second card is
the Jack of Hearts.
The third card is
the Seven of Hearts.
The fourth card is-- and this is
the final card that Srini will
be able to see--
the Queen of Spades.
Now, everyone think to yourself.
You've got to see the
card, the fifth card,
that Srini is going to have.
Think it very closely
in your mind, think.
SRINI DEVADAS: All right,
definitely a clubs, definitely
a clubs--
OK, see-- and I'm getting--
I'm getting at Ten of Clubs.
BILLY MOSES: And it
is a Ten of Clubs.
SRINI DEVADAS: All
right, thank you.
All right, so I guess
I'll have to confess.
I'm not a mind reader, but
I also did not cheat, OK?
So there's an algorithm here.
And do you guys want to
know what the algorithm is
so you can go and try
this out, I guess,
when you go back home next,
or whatever, at your dorms,
or with your classmates?
So it's not as easy as
it might seem, simply
because the combinations aren't
really in our favor, right?
So if you think about
it, there's 52 cards.
So this is a regular
deck of cards.
You know, it's as I said,
there's no cheating here.
Billy showed me four cards.
So which means the fifth
card could be 1 of 48, right?
I mean, it's completely random.
You guys picked these five
cards completely at random,
so there's no way that
that fifth card could
be anything specific, OK?
So what Billy had to do
was, in the four cards
that he showed me, he really
had to communicate one of--
specifically, one
of 48 possibilities,
which is kind of--
you know, if you
look-- if you think about it,
then the math doesn't quite
work out, right?
And so if you just say--
so what are the ways--
how much information
could you imagine
communicating, in terms of
bits of information, right?
You know, in terms of
possibilities or bits,
how much information do
you think that Billy could
communicate in these
four cards, which
were also picked at random.
Obviously, they have to
be specific cards, right?
He just put them
up there, right?
So if I have four
cards, what are the ways
that Billy could
communicate information.
I mean, you saw what he did.
Any ideas?
Yeah, Ganatra?
AUDIENCE: The order
the cards are placed.
SRINI DEVADAS: The order
the cards are placed,
so that's a great answer.
But if you look at the order
in which the cards are placed,
how many different
orderings are there?
Four cards, how many
different orderings?
4 factorial, right, and that is?
24, so I'm not quite
at 48 yet, right?
So that's a bit of a problem.
So is there something else going
on other than the ordering?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The time rate
at which he put them.
SRINI DEVADAS: So
you mean the way
he put them up, you know,
slowly versus quickly?
Or did you mean something
with which was--
the time in terms of
exposure of the cards, or?
AUDIENCE: Have some variations,
for example, whether the red is
before black.
SRINI DEVADAS: Well, but that's
all part of the ordering.
I mean, you have to be
careful here, in that, I mean,
you can't do both, right?
I mean, you can't
constrain the ordering
and then say that there's
24 different orderings.
The moment you constrain
orderings, the number
of orderings shrinks, right?
So I will say that, as I said,
this is a very legit trick.
It's completely algorithmic.
We're going to write code
for it-- or I'm going
to show you code for it.
But there's nothing else
other than the ordering, OK?
He is-- there's no
sleight of hand.
There's no hidden communication.
You know, he didn't
stress words,
you know, Clubs meant
something, or you know,
Spades meant something else.
It was just the ordering, OK?
And so there's a gap here in
terms of 24 and 48, right?
And so what's cool about this
trick is that we're actually
going to be able to do
this original trick,
where the fifth card
could be one of 48,
because we're going to do
one thing that you probably
didn't notice, because we only
did the trick once, all right?
And so let me explain how
this is going to work,
with just sort of
randomly picking--
I'm just going pick
the top 5 cards,
assuming these are shuffled.
And you can assume these things
that are at random, right?
So I have five cards
that I've picked here.
And can you all see them?
OK, what do you notice
about these five cards?
Anything-- yup, Fadi.
AUDIENCE: There are four
types and five cards
so there's at least
one that is repeated.
SRINI DEVADAS: Right, so the--
so you're saying
the suit, right?
So it is clear.
This is true here.
You have the Seven of Clubs
and the Ten of Clubs, right?
Oh are these the cards that
you pulled out, or close?
Anyway, so they look pretty
similar to the ones we used,
but that's probably just because
we didn't shuffle the deck.
But obviously, if
you have five cards,
and you only have
four suits, I guess
you could call it the
pigeonhole principle from 6.042,
but you're definitely
going to have
a pair of cards that are going
to be of the same suit, right?
I mean, there may be more than
two cards of the same suit,
but you're guaranteed,
for any five cards--
let me just pick another five--
that two of them are going to
be of the same suit, right?
That's pretty much guaranteed.
And so we ended up
getting clubs again here.
And so you have Two and
Four of the same suit.
So the first thing that
happens in this trick
is, we use the first card
to give away the suit.
Or Billy used the first
card to give away the suit.
Doesn't quite finish
the story here,
because let's just
say that I'm going
to use the first card
to signify the suit.
So in this case, let's just
say I am going to do Clubs.
Now, I have a choice here.
I could-- Billy could
have hidden Two,
and showed me the Four of
Clubs as the first card, right,
or vice versa.
And keep that in mind,
because that's actually
incredibly important.
But if you just say
that the first card is
going to signify
the suit, then let's
say the suit is now
out of the picture,
so I know the suit of the card.
How many-- so I have three
cards left, all right?
And I got a hidden card.
I know the suit of the hidden
card, but that card could be--
the hidden card-- how many
possibilities are there
for the hidden card now?
How many possibilities?
I mean, this is all at random.
Well, 13.
AUDIENCE: 12
SRINI DEVADAS: Oh, good
point, good, good, good--
see, this is exactly why
I need attentive students.
OK, good, so there's 12
possibilities since one of them
was--
one of them was shown, right?
So did that help us?
There are three cards left,
and so how many different--
I mean, the first card
is the first card,
so it's no longer part
of this permutation.
I can't count it in terms
of the permutations.
There's only three cards left.
And those-- certainly
those three cards
could be ordered
in a certain way,
but how many combinations
or permutations
are there of three cards?
Only six permutations, so again,
I seem to have a problem here.
I don't seem to have solved
the original problem of the 24
to 48.
I still have a 6-12 gap, right?
So we're going to have to
somehow cover that gap.
And any thoughts?
I gave you a little
bit of a hint
as to how this gap is going
to be covered when I talked
about the Two and the Four.
How am I going to cover
this gap, the 6-12 gap?
Yeah, Kanishka.
AUDIENCE: Possibly by
saying odd or even.
So if the next card you can say
odd or even you shrink it down.
SRINI DEVADAS: But
you mean-- say, you
mean Billy is going
to say something?
AUDIENCE: No, he's going
to present the next card.
SRINI DEVADAS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Whether it is thinking
that the final card you have
to guess is odd or even
and you can shrink down
the possibilities.
SRINI DEVADAS: So, I mean,
he-- the only thing he can do
is give me an ordering of the
remaining three cards, right?
Yeah, go ahead.
Kevin, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, maybe
you used the cards
to make a low-to-high
limit on the range.
SRINI DEVADAS: That's good, and
low-a-high limit on the range,
exactly right.
So what's happening here is, not
only do I have the first card--
and it's not the first card
is just giving me the suit.
I mean, that's the
way I said it, right?
But the first card also
has a number on it, right?
The first card has
a number on it.
So that number
could be an anchor
that is going to help me figure
out what the hidden card is,
right?
And what's important
to understand,
and this is really the
last interesting point
with respect to shrinking
these possibilities
or these permutations down, is
you want to think about your--
let me draw this out properly
in a nice little circle.
You don't want to think about
just a ascending sequence
of cards or numbers.
You want to think about this as
being circular, as you'll see,
for the following reason.
All right, so let's
just say the ace is a 1.
And so we're going
to think of that
as being the smallest number,
so you go 1 through 13,
in this case.
The king is a 13.
All right, so
that's your number.
And so you could imagine
you'd go 1 through 13.
So let's just do that first.
And then I'll explain to you
why I drew it in a circle.
And the first thing
that happens is,
I'm going to take
some card here.
And I'm going to make
that the first card,
so I don't care
about suits anymore.
And if I just picked this--
another five cards.
Let's just do this again, but
with another set of five cards.
And what do I have here?
Oh, I've got mostly hearts, OK.
So let me do something
more interesting.
This is too many hearts here.
Right, let's do this.
So now, I got a Two and a Jack.
And I got a Ten an an Eight.
OK, now I'll make this even
more interesting by picking--
I want to pick--
I want to get a hearts card.
And let's see how this works.
Ah finally, all right, so this
is what I have, King of Hearts,
the Eight of Spades, et cetera.
So the two cards with the same
suit are the Two and the Jack.
And so here's the
important thing.
One of the things that Billy
did, kind of, in a subtle way,
I'm assuming, and some of
you may have picked up on it.
The very first card
that he asked one of you
to pick certainly wasn't
the hidden card, right?
I mean, he got all five cards.
And then he decided
which of the cards
was going to be the
hidden card and then took
the remaining four
cards and encoded them.
And if you don't do that, if
you just say this, if you--
this trick won't work if
this is the hidden card.
This trick is only going
to work as it turns out
if the hidden card is a Two.
It won't even work if the
hidden card is a Jack.
And there's a reason for that.
And you-- can you think
of the reason for that
if you look at the board?
Can you think of
the reason for that?
Someone other than Fadi?
Someone else?
What do you see up here?
So what am I trying to do?
In terms of-- what
would happen--
you guys talked about--
Kevin mentioned distance
and things like that, right?
You know, you call
it the offset.
So what would happen if I hid
the Jack, and I did this--
I did something
like this, where I--
the Two of Diamonds was the
first card that was put out.
And then I tried to
encode and number
using these remaining
three cards,
what's the biggest number
that I could encode?
I mean, in--
I need to encode lots
of numbers, right?
So what's the biggest number
that I could encode here?
If I had six permutations,
and I start with one,
the biggest number that I
could encode is a 6, right?
Sadly, the Jack is too far
away from the two, right?
If I think of the Jack as being
an 11, it's 9 away from the 2,
right?
But help me out here,
what could I do?
If I flipped it, what happens?
AUDIENCE: Count backwards
SRINI DEVADAS: You
could count backwards.
Or what do I have up
there on the board?
What do you see up
I wrote something
that was linear,
but what do I have
up there on the left?
Circular, so you think mod,
mod arithmetic you know, think
of this as being circular, OK?
So what happens is that, if I
picked a 2 and a Jack, if I--
what I want to do
is to go clockwise.
OK and because there are only
13 cards, for any pair of cards,
it's always the case that I can
choose the first card in such
a way that the hidden
card is, at most, 6
away from the first card, OK?
Because you could get
into a situation where,
obviously, if I ended up hiding
the Jack and exposing the 2,
I end up getting a 9, which
is impossible to encode.
But if I hide the 2 and expose
the Jack, then I go 1, 2, 3, 4,
and I am at, basically, 4, OK?
So that's the last thing.
So let's just do
this really quickly
with yet another
set of five cards.
Now obviously we practiced so
we could do this fairly quickly,
right?
But-- and you can practice too,
but sometimes with things you
get lucky, you know, and you
get easy things to encode.
So what happens here?
Someone wants to-- so now
that you know the algorithm,
you have some choices here,
but obviously you have--
not all choices would work.
You've got to be a
little bit careful.
What would you hide?
So you need to make
sure that you get--
you can choose a pair of--
I'll make this a
little bit easier.
Sometimes choices make
things more difficult.
Perfect, all right, so
what you see here is--
you know that you have
to do the clubs now,
because you have the clubs as
being the suit that's repeated.
No other suits are
repeated, right?
So what am I going to expose?
And what am I going to hide?
That's your first
question, right?
Someone else?
You guys are all going
to have to do this trick.
That's the final
exam for this class.
On Friday next week, you're
all doing the trick-- no.
So what am I going to--
yeah, go ahead, Josh?
AUDIENCE: You are going to
hide the Ace, the King of Clubs
would be the first card.
SRINI DEVADAS: You're going to
hide the Ace, exactly right.
You want to hide
the Ace, because you
want to go this way.
And if you do it the other way
around, it's not going to work.
You're going to hide the Ace.
And you're going to make
the King the first card.
And now, what you need to
do is-- this is gone, right?
And now what I need
to do is, I need
to encode a number between
1 and 6, in general.
In this case, I need to
encode the number 1 in order
to give away the fact that
the hidden card is an ace.
And now I could do what
was suggested before,
which is have some sort of--
I mean, there's
obviously an ordering
associated with these
cards that you see up here.
If I call this a 1
and I call this a 13,
then lets do the
logical thing, which
is, 1 is smaller than 2,
which is smaller than 13,
but I might end up--
I might have and
Nine of Hearts here
rather than a Five of Hearts.
And I got to, obviously, be
able to order the Nine of Hearts
in relation to the Five
of Hearts as well, so--
because I-- all of these could
be nines actually, right?
And so I can't just rely on
the number to do the ordering,
so I can just choose
an arbitrary--
clubs is smallest.
Diamonds is the next.
And then I got Hearts.
I just did this because
this is a little bit
easy to remember for me.
You can do this in
many different ways,
in alphabetical order,
you know, C-D-H-S.
And so this-- that's moot here.
What I need to do is to
encode the number one, OK?
But I encoded-- in order
to encode the number one,
I have to have some sort
of way of ordering this.
And so what I'm going to do is,
I'm going to say SLM is one.
So what do I mean by SLM?
The smallest card is first--
I'm sorry, SML is--
increasing.
The smallest card
is the first one.
The medium card
is the second one.
And the largest card
is the third one, OK?
And I'll write this out.
And you can see the code for it.
But when you see something like
LMS, you're going to get a six.
And there's obviously six of
these different combinations,
right?
The details are actually
entirely up to you.
I mean, the most
important thing here
is the ordering that Billy had
had to be ordering that I had.
And so yesterday
when we practiced,
one time, there was a mismatch.
And we got it wrong.
But that's the only way
the trick would fail,
really, I mean, other than
human error, is if the--
is the encoding.
This is really encoding
followed by decoding.
And obviously, you need the
same algorithm, if you will,
which requires that you need
the same ordering, in this case,
for the cards, right?
So that's it.
That's the trick.
It doesn't seem that
interesting anymore, huh?
But no, it is interesting
if you show it to people.
And the fun part is
in actually doing it.
So I encourage you all to do it.
Any questions about
how this trick works?
So what I'd like to do is show
you some code for this trick.
And there's also a code that
was useful to both of us,
because we could
practice by ourselves.
We didn't have to be in
the same room to practice,
because I could randomly
generate a bunch of these four
cards.
And obviously, the program
knew what the hidden card was.
And I could--
I'll show you the code.
I could type in what
the hidden card was.
And it would say-- you
know, I guess it would say,
you're a mind reader
extraordinaire, or sorry,
not impressed.
And Billy could
do the same thing
in terms of checking
his encoding, all right?
And then, after we're done
here talking about the code--
and there are some interesting
things with the code--
let's talk about
whether you could--
talk about different
kinds of tricks.
And in particular,
I want to talk about
whether we could
go from five cards
to four cards using a
different encoding scheme.
Cool, so I wrote this
code about a year ago.
And I think I'd probably
write it differently now,
but we have what we have.
So the first thing is you
have to decide on an order.
You absolutely have
to decide an order.
And the cards themselves,
as I mentioned,
there's a natural order
associated with the numbers.
And of course, you can decide
if you want to start with a two,
and then the ace could be 14--
I mean, kind of makes sense
for you to go 1 through 13.
So that's really
what we have here.
The ace is the smallest card.
And the King is
the biggest card.
And as I mentioned,
the clubs are smaller
than the diamonds, et cetera.
So I just have a
deck of cards that
is ordered as you see up there.
And that's just a
Python list that
tells you what the ordering
of these 52 cards are.
Does that make sense?
So there's many procedures
here, many routines
that do different things.
And a lot of them
use the same code,
so I'm not going explain
each one of them.
But this one is a good one.
And I'll also show you
the computer assistant
one, which is essentially
this procedure except that it
allows--
allowed me to practice by myself
and generated cards randomly.
In this case, what happens
is, you input five cards.
And what this does is--
so you could sort of take
five cards out from the deck.
And then manually, you can
choose the hidden card,
order the remaining four.
And if you typed
in those five cards
into this particular
procedure, it
would give you the
first four cards, OK?
And so you can then verify
that you've done the ordering.
So this would be
something that--
I don't know if Billy used this
to practice, but he could have.
So what do I have here?
Well, the first thing is just
printing out what the order is.
There's a bunch of things
that need to get initialized.
Cards is simply a
list of five cards.
And then you have
c index, or cind,
which is the indices
in that giant list
that we have that
had 52 cards in it.
They're just the indices
of the various cards.
You can use .index, which is
a method to go from a card,
which is like a_c, for
example, to the index.
And then card suits are what
suits are for the cards.
And it's 0, 1, 2, and 3 for
clubs, diamonds, et cetera.
And then the numbers are
what the numbers of the cards
are, 1 through 13, OK?
You kind of need--
there's a bunch of bookkeeping.
As you can imagine, we're
doing things in our head here,
but if you want to get a
computer program to actually do
all of these computations,
it's not complicated,
but you have to worry
about the four suits.
And you've got to worry
about the 13 cards.
And you have to go ahead
and encode SML, or produce
this encoding, right?
So you can imagine
there's a bunch of code.
It's not complicated code,
but there's a bunch of code.
So the first thing
that happens here
is, in this
particular procedure,
you want to input
put these cards in.
And so let me just run it.
And so you get a sense of
what this procedure does.
All right, beautiful.
So let's just say--
let me just pick
five of these here.
So the first one
is Five of Hearts--
I'm sorry, Five of Hearts,
yup, Five of Hearts,
Nine of Diamonds, Jack
of Spades, Ten of Hearts,
Eight of Hearts.
And so it essentially
says the first--
so if I have
something like this,
it ended up choosing the
Ten as the hidden card,
and decided to choose
Five as the first one.
And then because Ten
was the hidden card,
you needed to encode 5, right?
And so the way you encode
5 is by encoding L S and M.
So the first card
that should be up
is a Jack, followed
by the smallest card,
which is an Eight,
followed by a Nine.
So that's essentially it.
So now that you've seen
that, let's take a look.
I'm not going to go through
every line of code here,
but I want to point out a couple
of things that are interesting.
This is simply filling
in the data structures.
The only thing that's
interesting here,
or the thing that's probably
the most interesting
here is what I've highlighted.
This is a way of taking an
element in a Python list
and getting the index for it.
And so that's essentially
something that--
it's object-oriented
programming.
We probably want to get
into that in this class,
but you'll definitely see
that in 009 and other classes.
And essentially, what we have
here, given the ordering,
is the suits simply correspond
to whatever the indexes mod 4.
Because, as you
can see from this,
the clubs are-- this is 0,
the index 0, and the club
is index 0, 1, 2, 3, 4.
So you're going to
get mod of clubs
is always going to
be-- mod 4 of clubs
is always going to be a 0.
Mod 4 of diamonds is always
going to be a 1, et cetera,
so that's essentially
what happens here.
And the first thing I
need to do is figure out
two a card that have the same
suit, because that's important,
because that's going to
determine what my first card is
and what my hidden cards are.
And that's what
happens over here.
And then once I
have that, I need--
I've just got to split these
five cards into two piles, one
of which has the hidden
and the first card in it,
and the other pile has the
three cards that correspond
to the ordering in it.
Obviously, the
computations that I
have to do for the
first couple are
quite different from the ones
for the remaining three cards.
In one case, it's ordering.
In the other case,
it's a comparison.
And I do have to-- the most
interesting remaining part
of the code that
I'm going to show
you is the determination
of what the hidden card is
and what the first card is.
And that's going require--
this is the part that actually
took me the longest to code.
I got it wrong a
couple of times.
It's going to require me--
it's five lines of
code, but it's subtle.
It's going to require
me to kind of figure out
whether it's a jack versus
two, you know, or vice versa.
And things get a
little bit interesting.
For example, if you had--
if it wasn't the Jack and the
Two, the example I had here,
so let's do this--
put the Jack and Two.
Let's say I had a
Three and a Ten, right?
They're kind of
the furthest apart.
And you had to be kind of super
careful here, because 3 to 10
is obviously 7,
which is too large,
but you need to go 10
to 3, which is 6, right?
So the things that
are diametrically
opposite to each
other are usually
the hardest when it comes
to actually doing the trick,
but it's also hard from
a standpoint of coding.
I had to get the mods
right, and the subtraction,
and in terms of what got
subtracted from the other.
So the rest of it is--
I just have high
level descriptions.
Obviously, the code for
these individual subroutines
is in the file as well, but this
one determines what's hidden,
what the other card is, and
what the number that you
need to encode is.
So when you go do the split,
and you have the two cards,
you obviously need to
decide which one goes first,
which one is hidden.
And you also get the number.
And that number had
better be between 1 and 6,
otherwise this is
not going to work.
And then you remove the other--
the two cards hidden in other
from the set of five cards.
In order to actually
do this SML,
it was a little easier for
me to sort these cards.
And then, depending on
the number and code,
I'd change the order.
Obviously, if I sort the
cards, I'm going to get SML.
And that may not be what
I want, but it's easier
to start with SML,
saying, this is
the order that gave me the
number 1 as an encoding.
What do I need to do in order
to change that encoding to a 2,
or 5, or a 6, or what have you?
OK, and so that's what
this outputNext3Cards does.
This is what took me
the longest to code.
I mean, it was a few
minutes, but the rest of it
was pretty much busywork.
There wasn't too much thinking.
So this thing here, as you
can see, the encode is done--
you don't need to worry too
much about the list itself,
and the indexing into it.
The bottom line is I need to
figure out this situation.
And I need to subtract.
And so when I see something
that says 10 and a 3,
I end up getting a 7.
And then I know that I
have to do a flip, OK?
But it also may be the case that
I might get something that--
the reason I need the mod 13 is
partly because I might end up
getting a negative number.
So it's not clear that
encode, take away the mod 13,
is going to give me
a positive number.
I might be subtracting 9 from 2,
so I end up getting a minus 7.
So you don't know this.
I mean, the program doesn't
know which one is which.
And it has to figure
out which one is which
and flip them together.
So if there's any code that
you want to look at carefully,
it's this code.
And it's just a matter
of sort of going
through the combinations
and making sure.
I know it works, but you need
to convince yourself it works.
So that's pretty much it.
There's not much
more to say here
that wouldn't be obvious to
you looking at it carefully,
so I don't want to
belabor the obvious.
And outputNext3Cards is the
part that I just described.
You start with the default
ordering, which encodes a 1.
And then you need to do
a little bit of flopping,
if you want to encode
a 3, for example.
And if you want to
encode a 3, then you'd
change things around.
And this is exactly what
I described to you before.
So this is actually
fairly straightforward.
If you have that table
written in front of you,
you just go off
it and write that.
Certainly if you change
the algorithm, all of this
would change quite dramatically.
And there's an
exercise which asks
you to do that, which you
could certainly try to do.
I want to show you one other
thing, which is interesting.
And then I want to run
this new subroutine.
So what I have
here is, I'm going
to run-- oh, I've
already run it.
So I want to show you
computer assistant.
It was very useful to me.
And this says, please
give me a random number
of at least six digits.
So obviously, I
don't want to know
what the hidden card is
if I want to practice
in a legitimate way.
So what I did was,
I said, I'm going
to have this sort of hokey--
I mean, it's really hokey.
I'm going to have this
hokey algorithm that's
going to take this giant number
that, I'm going to type in.
And it's somehow going to
take this giant number.
And it's going to
deterministically generate
5 cards based on
this giant number,
but I didn't want to
have an obvious way.
I mean, I don't want
to say the number 12345
and then end up getting the
first five cards in the deck,
or something like that, because
that would sort of give it
away right.
So I want to have some sort
of obfuscated way of taking
a giant number and
generating something that
was at least unpredictable to
me in terms of the five cards
that are generated.
And so what I do is,
if I type in a number,
some random number.
And at this point,
I have no idea
what the five cards that are
going to be generated are.
And this just tell me-- it
does do the assistant order
the cards functionality,
so it does take those five
cards, hides a card, and then
exposes the four cards to me.
And so I'd get
different-- depending
on what number I type.
So the way I'd practice
is I'd just sort of
close my eyes and just
type some random number.
And then it would produce
four cards for me.
And notice that
this is wonderful.
Notice that there's
a bug, right?
This is exactly
why I put this up.
And wow what luck, so notice
that this didn't work.
You know, and that's the fix.
That's an exercise.
I'm not-- I kid you not.
It's an exercise
that's going to be
up there, which is fix my
hokey algorithm so it doesn't
do this.
And so what happened here was,
I had a deterministic way.
This wasn't a random
number generator.
The good way of
doing this would have
been to use Python's random
number generator facility
and not have me do anything,
because obviously I
attached something that turned
into that, which is a deck that
has two King of Hearts in it.
And so my deterministic way,
which was a convenient way
because it's only
four lines of code
didn't need me to include
the Python random library,
et cetera, causes trouble.
So this obviously won't work.
So I'll just type something.
And it's going to say,
sorry, not impressed.
OK, not impressed with my guess
and not impressed with my code,
so let me do this again.
And so let me just do that.
And now-- what?
Is this-- this is ridiculous.
I mean, does my code even work?
I'm going to blame
it on my computer.
I told you my
laptop is acting up.
OK.
1111222-- ah-- thank you,
all right, so now I see this.
And I say Seven of Clubs,
so that's the first card.
So clearly, it's a clubs.
And then Ten, King and
Six, so Ten is medium.
So I got medium, large--
MLS, right?
So MLS, is--
MLS would be 4, right?
So 4 would give me the
Jack of Clubs, right?
There you go.
So this worked, OK?
But now I want to show--
you the last thing
I'll do is show you this code.
And you guys should
absolutely fix this code.
It is clear what
your exercise is.
Or you could--
I do want to talk about
doing this with four cards.
So, as note is that, this is
the offending line of code, OK?
So what I did was, I wanted
to generate five, kind of,
random-looking numbers
out of this giant number
that I typed in, right?
And I got lazy.
And I was tired of
this puzzle by the time
I ended up coding it.
So I just said,
you know, I want--
I don't want to include
random.lib from Python.
I'm just going to take this.
And I'm going to do some sort
of iterative computation, where
I'm generating what I think are
random numbers between 1 and 52
from this giant number
that I typed in.
And I'm going to
do this five times.
And what happened,
as you saw, is
that I generated the same number
twice a couple of times, right?
And that's why, obviously,
the trick doesn't
work in that case, right?
What was interesting
was, the way
I found this bug was not
the obvious way that we just
saw here.
It was actually something
where the hidden card
was the same as one of the
four cards that was exposed.
And I didn't know that, right?
So I'm like, what?
Why am I not getting this right?
It kept saying,
sorry, not impressed.
And what it meant was, it
wasn't impressed with my coding,
not with my deductive skills.
So it took me a while
to figure this out.
And you can fix it.
OK, so that's it.
Any questions about the--
what we've talked about,
the puzzle, or the code?
OK, so in the five
minutes that we have left,
let's talk about
whether there would
be a trick which would
be perhaps even more
impressive where we would
only use four cards.
So it would only be four cards
that the audience selects.
And we would--
Billy, I guess, would
show me three cards.
And I'd have to
guess the fourth.
Would that be possible?
I mean, the numbers
really don't work right,
because that fourth card
could be one out of--
I guess, if you
show three cards,
one of the 49 different
possibilities.
And it would be pretty
difficult, right?
You could think about
something where--
the only way I
could come up with
was-- it required
much more encoding,
but I was thinking
about something
like this, where let's say I
have these four cards, right?
And let's even take--
let's say that they're
all of different suits, right,
because that's possible.
The other thing that
happens when you have--
when you only have
four cards is they
all four could be of
different suits, right?
That's certainly possible.
What do I want?
I want a heart.
OK, good, so I have
something like this.
And now I'm in real trouble.
I mean, clearly,
anything that we talked
about isn't going to work.
So let's just say that I end
up choosing one of these cards
to hide, right?
So this Ace is hidden,
because it's not
quite clear what I
can do here, but bear
with me for just a minute.
So for argument's sake, let's
say that now, at this point,
I'm trying to get more
information out of this.
The ordering isn't
going to help me.
I mean, the ordering is going to
help me a little bit, but what
am I going to get, like 6--
1 through 6 from this?
So I could say the first
card is an anchor, OK?
And so I'm going to expose this.
So the only thing I could think
of was, you could sort of do--
this is a little bit obvious.
And I'm maybe
giving things away.
But depending on where
you have the hidden card,
and you can get more
information based on the order
in which you put these cards
out and whether they're
to the left or the right
of this hidden card.
So you'd need to do
something like that.
I mean, I haven't
figured this out.
At least, I can't think
of a complete solution
to this puzzle, but I
do feel like that you
can get some information,
additional information based
on whether you put things
to the left or the right.
And that's clearly a bit of
information that you get.
And maybe you could add to that.
And you know, think about it.
I think it makes for an
interesting exercise.
And obviously,
there's other ways
of doing the five-card
trick, as well.
Cool, all right, that's
all I had for today.
If there are no
questions, we can
close this particular session.